[Música]
la alianza de ultraderecha liderada por
Georgia meloni se impone con
contundencia en las elecciones
legislativas de este domingo en Italia
según los sondeos a pie de urna la Ultra
derechista se convertiría en la primera
mujer en llegar al cargo de primera
ministra y dice que gobernará para todos
tenemos reporte desde Roma
el presidente de Ucrania anunció
resultados positivos en la contra
ofensiva contra las tropas en rusas por
los di merceles que asegura que su
ejército lucha en regiones clave
mientras algunos ciudadanos se ven
forzados a abandonar las cuatro zonas
que Rusia Busca anexionarse con una
serie de referendos tenemos en reporte
de nuestro equipo sobre el terreno
una devastación inmensa así definen las
autoridades de Canadá el impacto de la
tormenta fiuna en la costa este del país
que deja al menos un muerto se estima
que se tarde meses en Reparar los daños
de este fenómeno atmosférico sobre
infraestructura claves de la zona
afectada
tiempo de actualizar las noticias en la
pantalla de Francia 24 Gracias por
continuar con nosotros Yo soy Juan
pupiales empezamos en Italia en donde la
ultraderechista Georgia melón y va de
Camino hacia la nueva primera ministra
del país según los sondeos a pie de urna
que auguran que la colisión de meloni
ganaría entre el 41 y el 45% de los
votos de confirmarse la victoria de
veroni sería ella la primera mujer en
llegar al cargo y también sería la el
regreso a la extrema derecha por al
poder por primera vez desde la desde el
fin de la Segunda Guerra Mundial meloni
le diera una alianza que comparte con el
ex Primer Ministro Silvia berlusconi y
Mateos alvini antiguo ministro del
interior en sus primeras declaraciones
después de la jornada electoral aseguró
que gobernará para todos y reconoció que
necesita de contribución ante la
dificultad de la situación
proyecciones por lo que podemos ver en
las primeras proyecciones podemos decir
que los italianos han enviado un mensaje
claro a favor de un gobierno de Centro
derecha liderado por hermanos de Italia
[Aplausos]
mate a gobernar esta naciones si estamos
llamados a gobernar esta nación lo
haremos por todos los italianos lo
haremos con el objetivo de unir a las
personas de potenciar lo que nos une en
lugar de lo que nos divide
previamente nuestra corresponsal en
Italia Irene salvia nos envió el
siguiente informe desde Roma la extrema
derecha ha ganado las elecciones en
Italia a falta de conocerse los
resultados definitivos este lunes Esto
es lo que dicen los primeros sondeos a
pie de urna de diversas encuestadoras y
también las primeras proyecciones
parciales difundidas en el país después
de 19 meses de un gobierno técnico de
Mario draghi y una mesa de campaña
electoral Italia un país miembro
fundador de la Unión Europea seguirá
siendo foco de atención Durante los
próximos días y probablemente también
las próximas semanas preocupan ciertas
voces de simpatía hacia el presidente
ruso Vladimir Putin que en estos
momentos sigue manteniendo una guerra en
Ucrania voces que se encuentran en la
colisión derechista ganadora de estos
comicios en los resultados que se
conocen en estos momentos pero también
preocupan
de Italia sea el receptor de la el mayor
receptor de esos fondos de recuperación
postpandémico que ha otorgado la Unión
Europea a los países más afectados por
el covid fondos que y préstamos que la
Unión Europea ha dado a cambio de una
reformas que tienen que cumplirse si lo
estamos contando el regreso de la
extrema derecha al poder por primera vez
desde el régimen de Benito Mussolini al
tiempo que la percepción sobre la época
del dictador parece mejorar y cada año
unos 70 mil visitantes acuden a ver su
tumba veamos
su bóveda ocupa la mayor parte del
espacio del cementerio de predapio el
lugar de descanso eterno de Benito
Mussolini en el pequeño Pueblo donde
nació se ha convertido en un santuario
al padre del fascismo atrae a unos
70.000 visitantes al año que depositan
flores y velas una especie de
peregrinación impulsada por la nostalgia
de lo que consideran una época dorada de
Ley y orden bajo el Antiguo dictador
si se revisa bien la historia de Italia
Mussolini hizo muchas cosas buenas por
Italia
yuste la agricultura la seguridad social
los hospitales
quizá con alguien como él los demás
políticos se callarían dejarían de
pelearse y harían algo
más de 70 años después de que nazis y
fascistas casi destruyeran Europa su
imagen resurge aquí sus símbolos se
exhiben en los escaparates como esta
tienda de recuerdos que vende camisetas
con saludos fascistas o banderas con
esvásticas pero no todos los habitantes
de pedapio lo aprueban
toda esta nostalgia Por una parte tan
oscura de la historia de nuestro país y
del mundo me incomoda
esta nostalgia ha contribuido a llenar
el camino para el aumento del apoyo a
los hermanos de Italia de extrema
derecha su líder Georgia meloni dice
ahora que no hay lugar para el fascismo
en su partido Aunque sigue luciendo en
su logotipo la llama tricolor utilizada
por los partidarios de Mussolini tras la
Segunda Guerra Mundial desde su caída
ninguna figura extrema derecha ha estado
tan cerca de liderar Italia
cambiamos de tema del presidente de
Ucrania habló de resultados positivos en
la contra contra ofensiva de su ejército
contra las tropas de kremlin en las
últimas semanas que va ha conseguido
importantes avances en este conflicto
llevando a que esta semana el presidente
ruso Vladimir Putin movilizará
parcialmente a sus reservistas
escuchemos a celenski
se están produciendo intensos combates
en muchas áreas de primera línea que se
extienden en un total de más de 2.000
kilómetros Esta es la región de donisca
esta es la región de gerson y también
las regiones de nikolaive Y saporiya
tenemos resultados positivos en varias
direcciones Y pase lo que pasa esta
semana en Rusia sean cuales sean los
pasos que esté planteando el gobierno
terrorista en lo político o militar la
tarea de nuestro estado la tarea de
Ucrania no puede cambiar estamos
luchando por la vida y la libertad de
todos los ucranianos
precisamente son en algunas zonas en las
que Ucrania Avanza en esa contra
ofensiva en las que Rusia Está
celebrando una serie de referendos con
Los que buscan accionarse esas
localidades está empujado a muchos
ucranianos que viven en las zonas
ocupadas a abandonar sus hogares un
equipo de Francia 24 informa desde un
punto de paso entre el territorio
ocupado por Rusia y el controlado por
Ucrania
la frontera de la ocupación rusa se
encuentra Más allá de esta carretera
estas personas están de nuevo enteras
controladas por Ucrania a tres
kilómetros del frente tienen la
impresión de que por poco han escapado
de una trampa
pensamos que podríamos quedarnos hasta
final de mes pero en vista de la
situación nos fuimos enseguida
huyen de una movilización parcial
declarada por el kremlin esta medida
solo debería afectar a los hombres rusos
pero en los territorios ocupados se
celebra un referéndum sobre la anexón
rusa estos hombres hablan de urnas
llevadas de casa en casa y de un voto
organizado con poca libertad de elección
bien acompañados de al menos dos
soldados y a veces junto a un vehículo
con una ametralladora
cuando ves como organizan el referéndum
cuando van de casa en casa armados eso
te da una idea de cómo nos re rodearán
el pueblo traerán el autobús y listo
habremos desaparecido yo prefiero morir
por mi país que morir allí a voluntad de
Putin
estas personas pudieron abandonar los
territorios ocupados sin dificultad pero
para muchos jóvenes Ya es demasiado
tarde
en el último punto de control allí donde
los residentes pasan ya no dejan salir a
los hombres de 18 a 35 años los bloquean
el número de personas que llegan aquí a
disminuido En comparación con lo normal
por lo que sabemos que ha aumentado el
número de personas que quieren salir
algunos están reunidos con sus seres
queridos tras una larga separación a
otros no los verán durante un tiempo
dejados atrás Al otro lado del frente
vamos a Francia porque un centenar de
personas marchó este domingo por París
tiene una protesta en defensa del clima
desde emblemático panteón hasta el
Ministerio de economía está multitud se
manifestó cargando contra el sector de
la publicidad alegando que ese sector
promueve el consumo ha sido un fin de
semana de protestas en favor del medio
ambiente en el país con movilizaciones
similares el viernes También en París y
en León en donde hubo bloqueos contra la
empresa energética total energis
las autoridades de al menos cinco
provincias canadienses evaluaron hoy los
daños causados por la ahora tormenta
tropical Fiona que tocó tierra en el
este del país este sábado a su paso el
fenómeno atmosférico dejó un rastro de
destrucción sin precedentes y se
necesitarán meses para la recuperación
hasta el momento se reporta al menos una
víctima mortal Rafael Pérez nos cuenta
más
a su paso por la costa del este del país
el ahora tormenta tropical Fiona dejó un
rastro de destrucción en al menos cinco
provincias una de las ciudades más
afectadas fue post donde más de 20 casas
quedaron en ruinas entre una población
de 4000 personas
en ese momento les diré que solo estamos
en una pequeña parte de la comunidad
pero el nivel de magnitud de esta
tormenta es muy grande más grande de lo
que pensábamos
en otra ciudad los árboles caídos las
casas destruidas y largas Colas en las
gasolineras imperan en el panorama de
este territorio de Nueva Escocia en esta
región igual que en Isla del príncipe
Eduardo Terranova Quebec y nuevo
Brunswick cientos de miles de residentes
permanecieron sin electricidad las
predicciones eran de una tormenta masiva
una tormenta histórica ciertamente hemos
visto eso Fiona definitivamente dejó una
huella en la provincia el daño es
bastante desgarrador yo no fue la
tormenta de más fuerza en tocar suelo
canadiense tras su paso las labores de
recuperación iniciaron con el envío de
las fuerzas armadas para ayudar en la
remoción de escombros el Primer Ministro
Justin trudó convocó una reunión con el
grupo de respuestas de emergencia para
coordinar el accionar del gobierno en
las labores de reconstrucción
seguimos en América en Estados Unidos
Florida se prepara ante el avance de la
tormenta tropical Ian y amenaza con
golpear Cuba en las próximas horas y
convertirse en un huracán el gobernador
rondizandi se declaró la emergencia en
todo el estado hizo un llamado de los
residentes a estar preparados
continuamos monitoreando la tormenta
tropical Ian que se convertirá en
huracán muy pronto ciertamente dentro de
las próximas 24 horas probablemente será
un gran huracán actualmente se encuentra
a unas 660 millas al sur de Cayo Hueso
también está al sur de Cuba es
importante señalarles a las personas que
el desarrollo de esto Aún es incierto
los impactos serán amplios en todo el
estado de Florida
Cuba celebró este domingo de la jornada
de votación en el referendo sobre el
nuevo código de familias una legislación
entre otras cosas abriría el camino a la
legalización el matrimonio igualitario
las urnas cerraron a las 7 de la noche
hora local después de que el sufragio
tuviera que extenderse una hora en siete
localidades incluyendo la Habana y
Santiago por condiciones meteorológicas
hasta las 4 de la tarde el 54,8% de los
8,4 millones de electores habían
ejercido su derecho al voto el nuevo
texto planea cambiar el actual código de
1975 y también planea regular sobre la
violencia de género
pretende ser el primer intento de la
humanidad en desviar un asteroide la
NASA está lista para comenzar su prueba
de defensa planetaria en caso de que uno
de esos cuerpos rocosos amenazar a la
tierra Por eso se ha proyectado un
cohete en dirección a un asteroide para
desviar su trayectoria y se espera que
el impacto tenga lugar el lunes por la
tarde un informe de nuestros colegas de
una nave espacial de varios millones de
dólares chocando contra un asteroide
normalmente sería un accidente caro
frente al cual los científicos
temblarían pero el lunes por la tarde la
prueba de redirección de asteroides
doble de la NASA llamada Darth
colisionará con el asteroide dimorfos
con la esperanza de alterar ligeramente
su trayectoria Es la primera vez que se
intenta una operación de este tipo
por primera vez cambiaremos de forma
medible la órbita de un cuerpo Celeste
en el universo esto tiene un claro
beneficio al asegurar la capacidad
humana para desviar posibles asteroides
amenazantes en el futuro
asteroides amenazantes como los que se
vieron hace 65 millones de años después
de que uno causará la desaparición de
los dinosaurios o más recientemente en
2013 cuando este meteorito dejó 1600
personas heridas en Rusia la misión Dark
se lanzó en noviembre del año pasado una
nave espacial de
millones de dólares no más grande que un
automóvil y más pequeña que la roca de
160 metros de ancho que no supone
ninguna amenaza para la humanidad La
misión de la NASA se ha planificado
cuidadosamente Para que no haga
colisionar el asteroide con la tierra
hay un 0% de posibilidades
independientemente
de que este asteroide venga hacia la
tierra en realidad es una situación
ideal para que nuestros equipos es de
científicos e ingenieros no solo de la
misión darta sino de todo el mundo
aprendan y mejoren con esta misión
Dark se estrellará contra Jim morfos a
22,500 kilómetros por hora el lunes por
la tarde en Estados Unidos el primer
evento transmitido por la NASA en caso
de éxito la misión era de la agencia
espacial europea seguirá sus pasos
lanzando su propia nave espacial en
octubre de 2024
concluimos así este misión informativa
la invitación es para ustedes para que
continúe en nuestra señal y también en
nuestro sitio web France 24.com
[Música]